je dis que après le départ de mon épouse
si j'avais pas eu Abdel je crois que je
serai pas là aujourd'hui devant vous
quoi
une relation absolument extraordinaire
le son de courage c'est le privilège que
j'ai là-bas quelqu'un comme abdelieu
Perez dans l'ombre comme vous savez
c'est un milieu très isolé
et grâce à
l'activité l'énergie d'Abdel j'ai
Laurent un peu de lumière et je reste un
peu dans la lumière comme c'est vraiment
le Roi Soleil
j'en profite beaucoup Abdel pour vous
Philippe pozzodi Borgo qu'est-ce qu'il
vous apporte alors il m'apporte l'avenir
il m'apporte une partie du passé du
présent il m'apporte certains délires
que je n'aurais jamais pu faire de toute
manière vu ma situation mais plutôt me
présenter chez un banquier demander un
crédit c'est même pas la peine alors
qu'avec monsieur Lecomte ça passe
beaucoup plus facilement une vie à
laquelle vous n'aviez même pas rêvé ça
ne serait même pas on sait que c'est
complètement inaccessible donc
c'est peut-être le rêve de certains mais
on n'ose même pas y arriver dans le sens
où on serait peut-être déçu de la suite
ce que certains appellent la facture
sociale il appelle ça un monde
d'extraterrestres
on est dans un monde d'extraterrestres
Abdel en fait c'est peut-être lui qui
vient à mon plus dur et qui avait pas
accès à ce monde qui est pas
extraterrestre qui a moins de actif dans
lequel il faut être puisque vous avez le
moyen de réussir justement Philippe
zodibo il n'y aurait pas eu cet accident
est-ce que vous auriez rencontré Abdel
ou quelqu'un comme lui est-ce qu'il y
avait déjà
mélanges de ces deux mondes auparavant
mon épouse-moi recevait des étrangers du
monde entier dans l'entreprise que je
dirigeais il y avait des gens de toutes
les conditions
si c'est toi j'ai jamais vu un Abdel
mais je crois que ça s'invente pas là
c'est c'est tout à fait le hasard qui a
fait qu'il est arrivé devant moi un jour
au moment où ma femme était au plus mal
il se présente pour faire tamponner son
papier de la NPE et repartir plus vite
possible et puis
ce que je voulais justement vous
demander en savoir un peu plus sur sur
la façon dont Abdel est arrivé chez vous
excusez-moi mais vraiment ça en basket
en disant j'ai lu une petite annonce ce
matin il était le premier à 8h30 la
première fois que la lance s'était mise
je viens juste pour faire taper mon
papier mais dites moi toujours ce que
vous avez à proposer
je ne m'attendais même pas à rester dans
le sens où bon vu mon origine vu la
période en 95 c'était tout ce qui se
passe en Algérie
me pointer je suis une famille de
bourgeois
[Musique]
d'origine arabe sortant d'une cité donc
j'avais je dirais 99,9% de chances de
refaire demi-tour donc je me suis dit
pourquoi pourquoi me présenter mais vu
que là il peut nous oblige à nous
présenter Jean basket langage non
soutenu
ça veut dire gain de temps et rentrer
chez moi le plus rapidement possible
malheureusement quand j'ai eu le
contexte et qui m'a quand même gardé
je dis pas que c'était des plaisant
c'est pas vrai mais le contact était
très bien passé j'ai jamais vu
d'handicapé devant moi pour moi c'était
un extraterrestre sur un fauteuil
roulant sur un objet roulant identifié à
distance
et tout était extraterrestre
justement vous avez quel âge vous Abdel
là quand vous êtes arrivés vous étiez
tout jeune tout à fait 25 mais ça nous a
pas fait peur justement ce travail ça
aurait pu aussi être effrayant non c'est
pas le travail qui fait peur c'est le
fait déjà on ne sait pas à quoi
s'attendre on arrive dans un milieu
appartement 500 m² pratiquement
ça change de la chaleur avec le super
grand jardin c'est vrai que c'est une
autre si une autre planète
pourquoi rester je sais pas pourquoi
d'ailleurs je suis encore là mais bon
la question pourquoi je ne resterais pas
c'est une bon sens
de motif de rester 0% de motif de partir
j'ai tout ce que je peux
vouloir aussi bien la situation aussi
bien les délires aussi bien les
amusement les loisirs les voyages
l'amitié
j'ai quelqu'un qui étudié encore une
fois je le répète peut-être 20 ans de
plus que moi ça m'a évité d'aller à
l'école au lieu de faire polytechnicien
lénarque ou ce que vous voulez il y en a
qui l'a fait à ma place
donc c'est un économie d'argent de temps
d'étude
pourquoi j'ai la possibilité de
rattraper 20 ans
mais non pour trouver un polytechnicien
surtout en ce moment
je connais pas encore le nom des
diplômes je dirais 20 ans
[Musique]
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que vous dites Philippe
dans chacun fait sa comptabilité
personnelle
je dis que après le départ de mon épouse
si j'avais pas eu Abdel je crois que je
serai pas là aujourd'hui devant vous
même si mes enfants étaient une
obligation une ardente obligation comme
moi on peut le dire je suis pas sûr
d'avoir trouvé d'avoir trouvé l'énergie
qu'il fallait pour revenir
c'était une période très noire donc vous
êtes vraiment indispensable l'un à
l'autre complémentaire complémentaire
est-ce que vous êtes étonné vous de
votre de votre parcours Abdel a
complètement du môme de la cité vous
retrouvez par parlant avec Philippe
Pozzo di Borgo de
projet au Maroc je dirais même pire je
me demande ce que je fais encore là dans
le sens où éclater autant de voitures à
quelqu'un et savoir qu'il est toujours
là c'est à dire acheter une grosse
voiture une belle Jaguar toute neuve et
trois jours après on lui dépose les clés
en lui disant c'est tout ce qui reste de
la voiture
monsieur s'offre une race je me dis
j'aurais dû éclater beaucoup plus tôt
par semaine à peu près c'est tout
que vous achetez vous
et moi non plus au point on a arrivé
jusqu'à créer une société de location de
voiture uniquement pour ne pas tomber
peut-être en panne de voiture
[Musique]
il s'appelle
eRTON Abdel c'est vous dire
pourquoi vous vous acceptez vous tenez
ça parce que une fois qu'on est passé de
l'autre côté
très près du noir comme peut-être la
mort on prend un certain recul sur les
objets matériels et c'est contingences
pourraient peut-être faire des d'autres
personnes mais moi
je réagis pas à ça en fait vous
ressemblez énormément et c'est comme
impact à la vie à la mort non
je pense que c'est à la base une énergie
vitale
qui était un peu interrompue chez moi
surtout parlait de mon épouse plus que
par l'accident d'ailleurs
ce que jusqu'au deuil de mon épouse
j'étais stratégique que ce soit pas je
marchais sur les eaux mais Abdel à cette
énergie de la vie ça fait du bien mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a aussi mes enfants
bien sûr
qui est un peu Abdel est un peu le grand
frère de mes enfants
paternelle Philippe à vos côtés il a
peut-être un peu plus je dirais qu'elle
est elle est tout elle est aussi bien
professeur d'école que j'ai peut-être
rejeté
paternel familial
formatrice
[Musique]
c'est le vrai Pygmalion quand même
je suis juste le train en train de
suivre les rails
le trou c'est ma tombe ça
voilà on fera un concours sur fauteuil
roulant mais bon pour l'instant je suis
encore là vous avez un langage de vérité
entre vous qui est absolument
saisissant on dirait qu'il n'y a plus de
tabou ce qui fait tout c'est l'humour
parce que la vie est faite de lumière et
d'ombre et même de noir serait
épouvantable mais avec l'humour comme on
l'a vu tout à l'heure
on récupère beaucoup de choses comme
vous êtes vous comme nous sommes tous
les deux on aime rire comme dans les
films
vous n'avez pas peur qu'à un moment
donné ils prennent de plus en plus de
pouvoir Abdel puisque vous lui conférer
de plus en plus finalement de de
possibilités aussi d'en prendre à quoi
il me servirait ce pouvoir
je suis un invalide
privilégié heureusement parce que la
plupart des envies de son dans l'ombre
il faut pas oublier
et analyse il a le grand avantage c'est
qu'il est plus dans le coup
quotidien de la pression quotidienne son
équilibre qui chez Abdel se trouve
quelque part entre
sans cœur et sous la ceinture excusez
l'expression chez moi ça se passe entre
le cœur et le ciel donc je suis très
très loin
du pouvoir de je n'ai plus d'appétit
là-dessus je préfère la lecture la
musique écouter les bêtises d'appel en
raconter voir mes enfants
vous le passage de la lumière la
réussite
effectivement à l'ombre la douleur la
souffrance les dépressions et ça et
aujourd'hui
l'espérance est-ce que vous appelez le
second souffle puisque vous publiez ce
livre aux éditions Bayard où vous
racontez justement vous raconter toute
cette trajectoire qui peut arriver à
tout le monde
je sais pas que tout le monde est né
le comment on peut peut-on dire ça c'est
trois petits points un bordel de
spaghettis
mais tout le monde peut a envie de
partir très vite de démarrer vite de
réussir d'être le premier
d'être dans la lumière dans les
paillettes
et un jour ça casse ça dérape la maladie
le noir absolu je fais près de moi de
coma donc il y a même plus de d'ombre
c'était noir là je sais plus on traverse
une petite lumière qui se pointe au bout
que ce soit un Abdel qu'il fasse le
guignol donc ce sont mes enfants
qui essaient de me faire rire ou qui
sont tout simplement présent
et bien on trouve que finalement la vie
c'est délicieux que les handicapés qui
peuvent pas bénéficier de cette lumière
aujourd'hui je reçois de trouver
l'attention que j'ai pu trouver chez
Abdel donc
trouver des proches une affection
une tendresse qui leur permettent de
sortir de ce trou noir et épouvantable
aujourd'hui qui est dans l'ombre qui est
dans la lumière on ne sait plus hein
[Musique]
je suis sous les projecteurs je pense
que son enfant c'était pas ça très très
dur que quand tu parles pas
évident évidemment très très dur et très
sombre Abdel il pète le feu il est
lumineux et moi je bénéficie de sa
lumière
tous les deux et je vous remercie du
fond du coeur de ce témoignage
absolument
magnifique et vivifiant pour pour nous
tous merci merci à vous deux pour ne
rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina Mireille
Dumas
[Musique]